good evening everybody and welcome to
the first of the workshop series for the
15k creative arts competition
my name is shannon rose mcauliffe and i
am joined here with my colleague theo
fields
say hello theo hello um
we're here this evening and we're going
to be discussing value propositions with
dr michael camp from the ohio state
university
i'm going to turn it over to dr kemp do
a quick introduction
and then we're off great well thank you
shannon thank you theo it's good to be
with you
i appreciate that all the way from
columbus ohio
as i was sharing earlier it's just a
little over 50 degrees today but it was
very cold yesterday so glad to be inside
glad to be on zoom
very excited to be able to share with
you tonight
let me go ahead and share a screen and
we'll get the presentation started
okay yeah just in the way of a brief
introduction i'll leave a lot of what's
on the slide in case
you're going to be delivering the slides
in
intact at a later point in time uh for
the most part just wanted to summarize
you know i'm currently at the ohio state
university
and have been there since 2004 however i
actually finished my doctorate work
there
back in the 90s and so i've been
associated with the ohio state
university for quite some time
i've taught at the fisher college of
business i'm now in the college of
engineering
i've actually run almost all of the
various
interdisciplinary hybrid experiential
educational programs in
innovation and entrepreneurship some of
them are now
on their own and i'm not involved with
them any longer
the langdale tech academy and a variety
of others and currently mostly
responsible for the icord ohio program
which trains research scientists and
graduate students in the advanced
principles of technology
entrepreneurship
and i'm working on some undergraduate
programming within the center for design
and manufacturing excellence on
innovation and technology
entrepreneurship there's not a big focus
is if you can believe that it was such a
big school
there's not a big focus from the
undergraduates in the engineering
program
on entrepreneurship so we thought we
better course correct there pretty
quickly
so anyway uh there's more detail there
on the
slide for you you know it was
interesting when i got asked to
share with you this evening i i
was a bit uh i guess the best word is
perplexed
because of the notion of what i
understand art entrepreneurship to be
and what the general theme of
entrepreneurship is and i thought what
might be a great way to start so that we
make sure we're all on the same page
is just to start with what i found to be
a pretty interesting
definition of entrepreneurship you know
the field of entrepreneurship has been
around since the 70s for the most part
as an academic discipline
and to a large extent the definitions
that we use in terms of researching it
and understanding what we mean by the
word entrepreneurship or entrepreneurial
behavior
really has never taken root there's a
lot of disagreement among the
scholars and there's a lot of effort to
make
the word relate to whatever might is the
best usefulness for the
the academic programs that you're
pursuing i found this particular
definition it's very consistent with
mine though it's got one small
variation but this was from james hart
and i liked it because he's from the
school of art
at smu he says that entrepreneurship the
creation of opportunity and value with
intent to profit
in a variety of ways through the
assumption of risk and effort
and one of the few examples that like me
actually focuses on the assumption of
risk
and when i was asked to speak on value
proposition this is a really tough
topic to speak on and i'll share as we
go through here in just a few minutes
why why it is very challenging
but for the most part it's because it's
at the center
of what entrepreneurship means the
notion of both creating and capturing
value
and also at the same time executing
your you know the discipline and the
mechanics of actually running a business
in order to capture that value
these are the critical components that
are
very challenging to actually identify
they're very challenging to evaluate and
they're very challenging to execute
and so for me this is the bread and
butter
of all entrepreneurship regardless of
art entrepreneurship
or otherwise and i thought to myself you
know i'm gonna
if you'll give me the permission i'm
gonna just uh
venture off here for just a second to
talk about what i think of when i think
of
arts entrepreneurship if you take the
definition we just identified
there's really three ways i can slice it
and i look at the
entrepreneurial effort as the enterprise
in the arts industry as one component
that is establishing the means by which
we buy and sell
art or artistic expression and
i would think of examples like
shutterfly i know the
competition you're in now is a strong
focus on the role that technology plays
in advancing
uh both the creation and distribution
and trade of art itself
i think this is one particular context
that makes an interesting
or would provide an interesting
perspective in terms of what we're
thinking about i'm sure
several of your teams are actually
focusing on arts entrepreneurship in
this regard
the means of buying and selling and
using technology to exploit
that however there's also the notion of
enterprise for the arts
and i thought it was a nice example of
michelangelo with the sistine chapel
you probably know well he was actually
paid to do that in fact
had to be bribed significantly in order
to leave a job he already had that he
was being paid for in order to take on
the job
and was paid what was at the time pretty
handsomely but took four years
to create so we'll talk a little bit in
a moment about the notion of value
creation and how
time investment costs opportunity all
come into play
and have to be considered in terms of
our venture opportunities as to whether
the value we're actually creating the
value proposition which we're
developing within our enterprises are
really worth
the opportunity or worth the effort and
thirdly the notion of enterprise
as art this is using our creative
expression to create sustainable
and long-lasting solutions for me this
is the essence of what i do
in entrepreneurship i don't i never
would have called it arts
entrepreneurship
or i don't call it arts entrepreneurship
but
for me the art is actually in the design
and creation of the underlying business
model enterprise
and how you can solve unique and
challenging problems in the world
through the power of enterprise and i
believe
just like a canvas of an artist my
business model
is a canvas by which i can create and
make lasting impact and significant
meaning
through the work that i do and so for me
i've had opportunities to develop
thousands of artistic expressions as
enterprise as art itself and i thought
this was just a nice way
to characterize depending on where the
teams are coming from i wouldn't have
any idea i haven't read any of your
original idea pitches and i probably
won't be there at the end to see
those pitches at the end of the the
final program
so just wanted to share that with you as
a way of contextualizing what we're
talking about
you know it for me i also am fairly
simplistic i like to break down the
concepts of something like value
proposition so once again to make sure
we're all on the same page so while we
have multiple contexts and wish to think
about
how we create value through our
enterprising initiatives
what is it that we're really creating
when we talk about
a value proposition and simply
put the notion of value is the
importance worth
or usefulness of whatever the target
focus is
whatever the thing is we're talking
about the proposition is a notion of a
statement that expresses that concept
and can be true or false and when i
mentioned earlier the notion of risk
therein lies the essence of risk in
terms of how we create value
in this instance our value propositions
the proposals if you will the
propositions we're making regarding how
our new enterprises are going to create
value
are actually statements that express the
concept
at its essence but also can be true
or false and that's the critical
distinction
what we want to talk about this evening
is regardless of context in terms of how
you're using your creative expression to
drive value through your enterprising
initiatives
the key here is that the basis on which
you determine what the value proposition
is
is either true or false and essentially
that's
what it comes down to you know the
fundamentals of value proposition though
i wish we had time i literally teach
an entire month of a two and a half
month course
on just this concept
typically we're working with high
technology businesses
however much of that technology
embeds the creative expression of the
research scientists who have
developed those inventions and so
there's a strong creative expression
that's actually
undergirding all of the initiatives that
we do and then understanding the value
of the proposition you have to ask
yourself
these key considerations or the key
fundamental questions
in other words the risk is if you go
back to the definition earlier
the notion of the effort the risk
associated
this question is is it feasible it's one
thing to have invented something in a
lab or to be
tinkering with something at home and
identify a unique way to
manipulate technology to create
different outcomes
the question however in value
proposition is can we really create
sustainable value
what is the value creating potential of
what we've developed or what we've
discovered
is it feasible and that's determined by
based on the notion of time
and cost associated with its achievement
again we can't simply stop with that
first initial discovery
we have to understand that if value is
going to be created it's going to be
solving problems and if so it's got to
be
introduced into the marketplace and so
the notion of the risk or the time and
cost associated with making it feasible
has to be taken into consideration when
we're thinking of value proposition
it's also the notion of value itself you
know go figure
but in this case the question is is it
different
in other words does it create new value
net new value and that value was created
by the degree to which the solution
addresses the core parameters of the
problem
and you may say resolves the problem or
resolves the core
components of the problem perhaps not
all the components you can imagine a
number of solutions
artistic or not that solve some portion
of a particular problem but only address
a particular piece and that needs other
solutions in order to derive
the total resolution and the third and
final is
is it necessary in other words
is it necessary means is it likely to be
adopted or utilized
and deployed and will there be an
opportunity for
this notion of what we call the trade
the transaction activity where
we capture the value that we embed or
create within
our products and services solutions and
that is
represented in the buy and sell
transaction activity
that happens around those new products
and services that we introduced
so think of your idea think of the
creative idea you're considering now as
part of this
competition is it feasible
how is it different if it's different
and why is it necessary
and you'll find that these are critical
questions that if you can answer
not only increase your confidence in the
enterprising initiative you're trying to
undergird
with the art uh art expression you also
find
that it's the essential element to build
your confidence
to move forward and those are the key
considerations in whether or not
you ever do start this venture you're
you're playing with at this time
you know this is an interesting quote in
the process of
trying to find this illustration to
drive home the point about the different
context
i came across a quote from michelangelo
and i thought it was intriguing
you know if you knew how much work went
into it you would not call it genius now
if any of you are art majors or art
students or are professionals you
probably have come across this it might
not mean much to you
but in the context of value proposition
and value creation this is a very
interesting quote to decipher
again we won't spend much time with it
but think about what that means with
respect to the notion of
the the overall art that was created the
effort that had to go in
to create this art and yes by the way
as i mentioned he was paid and was paid
well
uh according to the times
but what about the trade the buy sell
concept was it worth it do you believe
there was value captured now we look at
this piece of art today and we
see the intrinsic value i mean it moves
your soul
or should perhaps or that was the intent
but does it
ultimately have extrinsic value
and would it have been perceived as such
at the time
when i start to translate some of these
concepts into the type of ventures that
i start or help
to start on a regular basis whether it
be through my students or the research
scientists that we're training
or some of the consulting activities
just like artists use a canvas we use
what we call the business model canvas
and this is a
a very simple rendering of what the
business model canvas is and
and like most of these types of
illustrations
they really aren't in and of themselves
of any uh particular insight or value
the importance of this canvas is it's
simply a way
of organizing your information
ultimately
in order to articulate a clear and
compelling value proposition
you have to be able to show how it
embeds within an
overarching business model it's not
enough
to just simply describe a value
proposition in fact it's
it's not possible um in and of itself
if you see how the value proposition is
positioned within this canvas it's
directly in the center and
immediately to the right is the customer
segments
and all the ways in which the value
proposition serves
the needs of those customer segments
again depending on
you know the nature of that segment the
nature of the product service offering
there's a variety of ways in which value
proposition services but if you look
immediately to the left
these are all the ways in which we
create the value proposition that solves
and serves the needs
of the customer segments those
value-creating competencies around key
activities
key resources and key partnerships are
the critical backbone
of the notion of value proposition so
it's not enough to have a compelling
value proposition
it's only compelling to the extent we
believe you can deliver
and the only way we can believe you can
deliver if you clearly understand what
the key activities are that you're going
to need to master in order to deliver
that value proposition
and what key resources you're going to
have to have in order to
sustain that and where you don't have
those key resources what key
partnerships are you going to have to
build into your overarching model in
order to deliver that battle
ultimately to drive solutions to your
customers that are better
than alternative competitive solutions
on the market now
so this is really an organizing
framework but for me
from an artistic standpoint i envision
it as a very powerful
and compelling canvas by which we can
or lump of clay by which we can sculpt
a compelling business model and it might
sound like a play on words but i
actually do consider myself to be
fairly arts oriented i come from a
family of that sort
and i'm actually personality wise much
of a designer builder
type and i'm constantly whether i'm
building educational programs or
building startup opportunities
new ventures there's always a design
and a creative articulation that
is embedded in all of that work
what we're driving for here in a clear
compelling sense of this notion of fit
we want to understand clearly how our
solution
fits the needs or solves the problems
in a compelling way with the customer
segments and i'm going to come back to
this at least one other time
if not more and we'll explain there's
actually
more to that story but we have to
develop our thoughts here for just a
moment
when you get this deck
this will be a slide that you can use as
a reference slide
i'm not going to pour over this slide
this was actually from an article
i use in the mba class i thought it was
nicely summarized
as a way to consider what a value
proposition is what it consists of and
what challenges it addresses for the
customer what
is required in order for it to be
compelling and what are some of the
challenges and risks associated with it
and then you see
how that plays out across the different
columns what i'd
like you to what i would like to point
out and what i hope you'll discern when
you spend a little bit of time with this
is the notion of value propositions
direct link and time consideration of
the customer
and the customer segment and it's not
enough to simply know
who your customer is and while this is a
nice
additional a nice summary resource to
use it falls short in what i believe to
be
a critical component but once you know
that component and you read
this chart through that lens you'll have
a much more a deep and comprehensive
perspective of what these terms
mean and how relevant they are and we're
going to talk about
that perspective in a moment uh before
we jump to that are there any questions
at all well what we mean by value
proposition and what we mean by the
context of
value proposition creation and arts and
arts entrepreneurship
if people have questions they can either
unmute to ask dr camp
or we can you know i will happily
receive those through the chat
okay looks like everything is smooth
sailing so far so i will just let you
continue
very good i think it was would be fun to
just talk about
a good illustration i'm sorry i don't
have a better one
at the moment to match up with the arts
competition that you're going to
as i've said already though i do believe
that there's enormous
creative expression enormous use of
technology
in a lot of product markets that i spend
time
i my work has crossed over 36 different
technology verticals from the medical
to the software to materials and ag
related bio
products and so i i don't have a problem
transitioning or perhaps the better word
is translating these concepts from one
segment to the next
and and yet i see this as an enormous
expression of or an illustration that
expresses the
enormous potential in the role of value
creation
if you look at the notion of the keurig
code i don't know if anybody's familiar
with carried code and i wish i could see
you so you could raise your hand but
it's not that important the critical
consideration is you're probably all
familiar with the keurig hot
well before there was a keurig hot there
was just curing and the keurig hot came
to be because of the cured cold
and the notion of having to
differentiate how you get a hot beverage
versus you get a cold beverage
and this was a partnership that was
launched with keurig
in partnership with coca-cola to develop
the same type of
k-cup type technology that would deliver
a cold
carbonated beverage as opposed to a hot
beverage
and um i just wondered if anybody was
familiar with that
very very interesting very very exciting
technology
actually a beautiful design again in my
opinion extremely artistic extremely
well laid out
there are over 150 issued patents inside
of the keurig cult
that was developed along the way however
so
at the bottom line there's really
fundamentally nothing wrong with this
concept in its
technical sense fundamentally it can
perform if we knew that it was feasible
at work
this is actually an illustration taking
actually directly from one of those
patents the patent around how to
carbonate carbon um put the carbon
dioxide directly into the solution in
order to make the
carbonated beverage all of those little
individual pieces are actually
identified in the patent
so a very interesting piece of
technology
but one of the most disastrous new
product innovations of all time
i mean ranks up there as a classic even
if you haven't heard
of keurig cold if you understand the
facts behind this case you know exactly
how
disastrous this was it was pulled off
the market in less than nine months
about six years just shy of six years
and one billion dollars went into the
research and development of the product
it was taken off the market less than
one year after the company had already
been acquired so even in the acquisition
of the company the process with due
diligence
this product would have been evaluated
and so even the acquirers would have not
known that this was going to be as
disastrous at the time they acquired it
but more importantly 135 employees in
the state of vermont lost
their job and that's pretty unfortunate
and i would ask so what went wrong
well we could probably identify just
brainstorming a
half a dozen different concepts i could
tell you that
the cost of each individual eight ounce
glass of carbonated beverage was about a
dollar thirty two
uh the machine is about twice as big as
a curing hot
so it literally takes up a third of your
counter kitchen counter
it's also extremely heavy and there are
very few k-cups that were actually
available at the time there were several
coca-cola products but that was about it
and a few other but that was about
it but the bottom line is there really
was no problem
solution fit in other words if you
asked any of these engineers you you can
bet they had a very strong value
proposition
they were convinced even keurig and
coca-cola two of the top
consumer beverage brands in the world
who have millions of customers and could
gone to any number of those customers to
get
a clear compelling sense of whether or
not this product solved any problem or
not
and they didn't and if they did they
were biased in their approach
because it didn't show any evidence that
no one would want to buy it
oh and by the way the machine was about
650
when it first came out so about twice as
expensive as the curie hot when it first
came out and even more so
by the time it was widely adopted
so let's not get into any confusion that
any one of these elements is what was
the downfall the reality is
they were building a product nobody
wanted and
this is a critical consideration and i
know you're only at the idea stage of
your
your arts entrepreneurship competition
but i will tell you that it's at that
stage
where all startups begin and
the need for or intention to go beyond
that
must be driven by your clear
understanding
of the problem in solution fit you
remember
the value proposition again is this
importance or worth their usefulness of
something let's take the keurig code its
importance
was dependent on some key considerations
and those
statements of importance were either
true or false
and the best time to determine
the validity of those statements is now
today during the idea stage is the time
in which you
not only create the value proposition
you validate and confirm
the value proposition along the way we
have this precept and all of our
teaching
that's a nice quote i use quotes for all
of my precepts but
it's from mark twain that any what you
don't know that gets you into trouble
it's what you know for sure that just
ain't so
so the reality of testing the value
proposition of your business is not that
this value proposition lives in some
obscure reality that somehow
you know we've we've been enlightened in
terms of the needs of our market and we
know exactly what the customer wants
the reality is that's all driven by the
assumptions we're making which are
driven by our own biases and our own
ignorances and the own lack of
understanding
what really happens i can point you to
dozens of teams that were convinced that
they were going to solve a particular
problem
only to get testing into the market and
find out that the problem
didn't really exist or the solution was
way over complicated for the
notion of the problem so it's important
that we understand
and think about those carefully let's
look at this situation that has a near
zero probability of being correct this
is a new venture idea that was based on
the following assumptions you'd probably
recognize it right away
first assumption is that there are too
few affordable hotels
in the city for short-term stays
people are probably willing to pay for
alternative options if the hotels are
not available
people are probably willing to
compromise on some of those original
amenities in order just to save money
there's probably enough people that
would be willing to do this that
i could make a profit other people might
even be willing to rent one or more
bedrooms in their apartments
and there are probably enough people
willing to sub rent their apartments
that
we might be able to establish a
sustainable service
well it's no it's not hard to guess
airbnb
but and you know that that's a pretty
wild success
however if we were if you understand how
airbnb
actually was created you'll realize that
each one of these
individual steps were tested actually
live
tested with customers in the market
before they ever wrote a business plan
before they ever took out a bank loan
before they ever decided to find
partners
they literally just talked to their
friends and made their rooms available
in their extra rooms in their apartments
put a small website together and then
added more rooms and
by the time they ever wrote what might
be considered a business plan
they were already multi-million dollar
business and already had
actually achieved other uh other
successes as well
so but don't fret about the cured cold
rest assured keurig has figured out all
of its problems
and what went wrong and they've now
introduced
drink works home bar so although the
cured cold was a colossal failure
keurig is 100 convinced that drink work
home bar
a single serve pod based premium
cocktail spritzer machine
is exactly what we all want and this is
going to go rolling off the shelves
just anytime soon these are yes k-cups
that create
carbonated alcoholic mixed beverages and
that's it
they figured it out uh
yeah sure we'll see
however let's let's bring all of this
back a little closer to home
and looking at what we're dealing with
another near zero probability of being
correct set of assumptions
are exactly where you are right now
and in this instance with respect to how
your new venture will create value or
capture value
you're making some core assumptions at
least all the teams that i've coached up
through
this point of 25 years of doing this
typically make these assumptions going
in it's
why they decided to enter the
competition in the first place
there's a level of confidence in the
assumptions you're making about
your new venture idea you're assuming
that the customer you're focused on has
the problem you're focused on and knows
that they have the problem let's hope
that they've tried alternative solutions
and nothing's worked
up to this point they can articulate
what they need
that's a really big assumption and they
know how valuable
an alternative solution would be if it
solved that problem
and you're probably already making
assumptions regarding how much they
might be willing to pay
for such a solution at the same time
which is the second
side the risk side associated or
actually on the buy sell side of
associated with value proposition we're
assuming that the solution we can make
addresses those pain points and performs
better than anything already in the
market
and it doesn't require any significant
change in the current workflow
and doesn't increase the cost of
adopting our product over alternatives
and
we can sell it for x in order to sustain
the operations and make a profit
for our new venture some of you could
give your final pitch right now
some of you based on these assumptions
could
today write a business plan and pitch
for funding
it happens all the time
but remember that the key to a strong
value proposition
the key is the evidence to determine if
it's true
the evidence that is true is what
establishes your value proposition and
remember that the value proposition is
the
essential ingredient to your entire
business model
without a compelling value proposition
that you can prove is true you really
have left in question the entire
business concept
even though you may have a lot of other
aspects completed until this is
fully articulated there's really not
much else to be believed
there's very little confidence we have a
saying in the i-corps
training program in ohio that's a as i
said a
graduate student and research
scientist-led entrepreneurship
initiative
training initiative that we don't care
what you think
we're not really even interested in what
you believe
the only thing that matters is what you
can prove and that's
where value proposition comes in
so we're moving into the last segment of
our
our few minutes together are there any
questions about any of those
illustrations
and the importance of understanding our
customer segments and
and why that level of understanding and
depth of clarity
is necessary in order to generate a good
compelling value proposition
so far everything seems pretty clear to
me and i
am just desperate to see how that uh
cocktail keurig thing works out
[Laughter]
i stopped short of telling you that i
had bought one of those cured colds
however i bought it after i knew that it
was being pulled off the market
because i wanted to use it as a good
example
if we were in class this evening i would
have it sitting behind me and you'd get
a chance to at least try that
but i intend to get one of these too
particularly if it goes off the market
but either way i intend to get one of
these too
excellent i will look forward to a full
report
very good very good well we're moving
now into a bit granular
uh approach to actually understanding
you know how do we evaluate the customer
and the customer profile and what we're
doing and again
i have an entire 12-week semester with
uh
with finals and presentations and
everything around just this concept
alone
and this is at the center of the i-corp
program so we're going to get a few
minutes
and i apologize we can't go deeper i'm
happy to answer any questions in the
future
or future iterations or if there's you
want to email me i'll make my email
available so
happy to be helpful but we're going to
really cover it superficially so please
ask questions if i either go
too quickly or too uh to superficially
so
the notion of the business model canvas
as we showed a little bit ago
and i mentioned to you that the key here
is
clarifying this value proposition and
its link or fit with the customer
profile and the pains and problems the
customer is having and achieving the
jobs they're
intending to achieve well there's the
same group that develop that
that canvas map that business model
canvas developed this value proposition
canvas and
if you have familiarity with it i'm not
going to go into a deep dive in terms of
the dynamics of how the mapping works
but
i'm going to talk a little bit about
each of the individual pieces
i didn't want to bore someone who maybe
uses this in a number of classes and i
or you're using it now in the
in the program or i didn't want to be
too
uh loose with uh with any of these
individual pieces because you maybe
already covered it but this is all this
is
just a breakout of those two segments
but we
we break them out because it takes my
teams anyway
four out of eight weeks when we run the
eight week icor program it's at least
four weeks
before the teams can articulate to my
satisfaction
and i'll explain what i mean by that
before they can articulate clearly how
the
value proposition they create through
the products and services they offer
derive
drive directly value created into the
customer for the jobs he or she's trying
to perform
and it i let literally get them down to
that level of clarity
and when i say customers here i'm not
talking about in this case just
like the automotive market or the arts
industry
or the theater program i'm literally
talking about
who what job by job title would be
the user payer influencer of the
purchase of my product or services i'm
addressing if you can't articulate that
you
leave a big question in my mind as to
whether you really know
whether you create any value or not or
solve any legitimate problem or not
so these are not abstract concepts these
are literally down to hand-to-hand
combat we're literally talking
face-to-face in this case
zoom to zoom if you will we're talking
directly with our customers
let's talk for a moment about the notion
of the customer profile this is where
you want to start your customer
discovery activities trying to identify
do i have a compelling value proposition
or not
do i can is it feasible is it different
and
is it valuable does it matter
you know why should it exist these are
critical considerations the first thing
you have to understand is
you have to explain who do i assume is
going to use my product
and then who do i assume if my user
doesn't buy who's going to buy my
product so my customer can use it
and then if my buyer doesn't actually
use it or can't influence the decision
who influences the decision
so that my buyer can buy it so that my
customer can use it
and sometimes our our concepts are
you know business to consumer they're
direct their websites and these are not
complicated matters
other times they're medical devices and
there's 14 levels of decision maker you
have to go through in order to get them
approved so i'm not sure where anybody
is at any time but i can tell you for
sure
if you can't articulate it back to me in
simplicity
in a simple way and an effective and
compelling way
i'm not going to believe you know it
either and that's the key
what we're talking about today so in
this sense these are the set of customer
characteristics that
in the most important word is there that
you can validate
with actual customers in the market the
first thing you need to understand are
the customer jobs
and that literally is just asking the
customer that i think has the problem
that would use my product what is his or
her job
what is it they do they're a design
engineer at an automotive manufacturing
facility okay what do they do
okay they design parts they just they
design
systems they write software they meet
schedules
but then i asked the pains and gains
what i want to know there's well what
challenges what are the difficulties
they have at getting that job done
all their software is too archaic they
have too many different softwares that
don't link with
each other it takes too long it's too
much done by committee there's no
other design graphic software that would
make it more effective
whatever it might be and then the other
is the gains
what are the things they would like to
achieve but can't because they lack
the adequate opportunity or resource the
adequate product or solution that you
might
provide maybe they would like to be able
to save time
in the designs or share the designs with
more of the
different designers across their company
in order to get things facilitated more
efficiently or more effectively so a
host of those things
maybe not the best example but you you
need to understand your customer at a
detailed level in terms of what job are
they trying to create and what
challenges and gains are they trying to
achieve with that job
and on the value proposition side the
notion here
is that do we have a set of
characteristics that actually
allow the customer to achieve those
gains or
resolve those pains associated with
their jobs
and remember ultimately though we have
to be able to do this
better than the current alternative
products whatever the customer
if these are real problems the
customer's trying to solve
he or she would have already been
looking for alternative solutions in
fact they may have already been testing
and paying for solutions that they're
not happy with
and maybe even adopting them and using
because there's nothing else available
your best customer the best
person to understand what they need is
someone that's
already looking for solutions better yet
has already paid for
alternative solutions that they're not
happy with now you're not solving the
original problem
you're solving the problem that they're
having with the alternative
solutions that don't work well enough
all of a sudden now you've shifted
the priority and a higher level of
interest
in your product if it can resolve those
types of issues
so ultimately we're bringing all of that
together so when we've captured that
information we can put it on a graphic
something like this that says well how
do the pain
relievers um our pain alleviators
associated with our products and
services actually relieve
the pains of our customers in order to
allow them to do their job better
or better yet how do the benefits of our
solutions
actually drive new and improved
scenarios so the customer can either do
more
or do do more with less
and so it requires two things a clear
understanding of the jobs
and the pains and gains of the customer
and then an evaluation of how
your product actually matches or solves
or fits
the word fit in order to solve those
pains and gains
and that's what we mean by the notion of
problem solution
fit and this is why curing
didn't work uh or the carry cold anyway
why it didn't work i couldn't point
pinpoint exactly
but i could tell you just my own
experience i used to curate for years
and i would have could have told you
immediately that
the code made no sense to me and i would
not be interested in it
so as we wrap up here you know after
many weeks
of this particular program you're going
to be in for weeks and weeks and these
training workshops and the research on
your efforts and all the mentoring that
you're going to be getting
i found it interesting if nothing's
changed in the priorities or the
parameters of the competition
you're going to get five minutes to tell
your story
multiple weeks of training research and
mentoring and you're going to get five
minutes to tell your story
now the last thing you want to do
is try to fit all your information into
that five minutes
so you i i ask you
what is the storyline what is the
compelling
and convincing storyline that you have
to tell
in order to achieve a victory in a five
minute
presentation now you might be thinking
i'm going to say it's the value
proposition and
i would tell you it's not enough
it is the value proposition in terms of
its key role
but stay with me for one more second
we have to understand the customer
you only needed an idea to get into the
competition program
but to win you're going to have to leave
your idea leave it on the desktop
and get out of the building as commonly
referred to virtually if necessary
and talk directly to your customers your
business model why who who is your
customer first of all well
your evolving business model is it by
it's
in nature a value creation engine
therefore
everyone your business touches customers
suppliers
end users payers purchasers
whatever however it's delineated across
from start to finish on the decision to
buy your product instead of one of your
competitors
those are your customers and if you need
a partner in order to deliver
a unique feature inside of a software
they are part of your customer in other
words anyone who derives
value from participating with you in
your business proposition
is a customer remember you're doing this
in order to
create and capture value there's many
reasons why
some to sustain your enterprise but
others to
change the world and make a meaningful
impact and sustain that change so it can
impact people for years to come whatever
it might be
as a value creation engine think of your
enterprises in that way
anybody who derives or contributes
becomes a customer in your customer
discovery process
and here are the keys you got to
acknowledge the critical assumptions
that undergird
why you think this is going to be a
successful business and that means come
clean
get in a room with your team zoom room
if it has to be get in a room
and come clean on everything you're
assuming
to be true in other words ask yourself
what has to be true for this to be real
and then you're going to document those
and then go out and empirically test
those directly with your potential
customers
you need to be able to articulate with
evidence what problems
they are trying to solve not what
problem you think they have but what
problems are they trying to sell
what alternative solutions have they
tried where and what value does your
technology create if it solves the
problem better
your focus must be on understanding
their past and current behaviors
not opinions it doesn't matter if i said
you know if i had a product of this or
would you buy one and they said oh sure
it's it's a useless date it's not even
meaningful
ask them what was the last product they
bought to try to solve this
how did that work out were they happy
with the decision what didn't work out
what what are they looking for now and
what would they pay for a solution that
did
that is the no or what did they pay for
the solution that didn't work out that
is the notion of
what they perceive to be valuable or not
that's data you can trust
their past behavior is the key to
proving the value
in your proposed product or service and
then again wrapping up as we've said the
value proposition your ability to prove
that value proposition
is the essential element of how your
whole business model holds together
and remember five minutes just five
minutes you've got to get this across
in other words you've got to contract
your space you got to bring the message
in
you got to be very simple but in that
simple message
it's got to be clear and it's got to be
compelling in order for you to win
okay spoiler alert i know who the winner
is this year
i'm sorry shannon and theo i hate to
you know let the cat out of the bag but
the winner this year
is the team that can prove the problems
real the market's large the team can
deliver and the solution ensures a
strong and competitive fit with customer
needs
in other words can prove you'll hear a
lot of presentations at the end of this
program where the team's still
speculating they think they believe
they're confident
the team that can prove with evidence
directly from customers
that their value proposition is real is
going to
heads and shoulders above the others and
it's very clear in a five minute
presentation which ones
are able to achieve that
well i'm open i think that was it yeah
let the games begin
let the games begin oh fabulous do you
mind if i pop this back in a gallery
view so we're sort of you know
able to converse a bit absolutely
all right i hope there's a lot of open
conversation
all right so does anybody have any
initial questions thoughts it would also
be great to see some people on camera i
am familiar with some of you but not all
of you so it would be nice to sort of
see who's in the room and see what kind
of conversation we can get going
in the next few minutes
while people are thinking shannon i have
to ask i hate to admit i don't know what
that is behind you what is your
okay this is true this is king's college
chapel in cambridge over in the uk
uh probably my favorite place that i've
ever sung
because the acoustics on those fan vault
ceilings are
unparalleled i've never sung anywhere in
the states
maybe the cathedral of st john the
divine because it's just so
huge but any of the places where i've
done nice
singing um this is this takes the cake
that is awesome
all right all right well um for the
benefit of people who are watching this
asynchronously
i think uh one question in order to uh
to avoid being a keurig
and kind of continuing to kind of bark
up a tree that
maybe doesn't have value how should
teams think about
potentially changing their their big why
or their value prop
what's the best strategies for doing
that and how can you do that effectively
while still kind of preserving your
initial
mission yeah that's a a really good
question
just to be a simple about it i didn't
discuss the notion of
a term we refer to lean startup again it
might be a common term your teams or
students have used but the notion of of
this
customer discovery activity is because
we're trying to
go fast in other words we we want to get
to the nose
we know there's a lot of the assumptions
we're making that aren't real
or aren't true and in the process of
doing it effectively and doing it
deliberately we're going to uncover
where those gaps are
so trust me you're all of your ideas are
going to pivot they're all going to
modify either slightly or greatly but
the
how we do that is in the actually
derived from the discovery process
itself
i don't want you to think that this is
i'm going to go talk to a bunch of
customers and
realize my business is dead in the water
there's no nobody needs what i have what
am i going to do now
it's actually in the discovery process
by really being honest with yourself not
trying to simply validate that you have
the greatest solution in the world but
really understanding their problems
and understanding how they look for
alternative solutions now and what
they're willing to pay for those
solutions where the next
idea will emerge i tell my teams all the
time the last thing you want to do
is is uh go in with
i've got a one-step solution if you
don't want it you must not be smart
enough to know you need it
or you know i i'm out of business
that neither of those are true you're
going to learn
through the discovery process whether
your initial assumptions are right but
that
data is also going to tell you where
your appropriate pivots are
i've had teams go all the way to
different completely different market
segments
i could share those stories if we had
time but literally from one
medical segment to a drone they were now
doing battery powered
systems for drones all the way from
heart implants and what
literally in a five-week period and how
did they do that were they jumping
around
making no they started with a core
assumption they believed in
tested it invalidated and what they
learned from that validation or
invalidation told them
where to go next
so i hope that's a part answer that's a
great example that's
really that's a great example and i
think that's helpful now as people are
coming up with their ideas because
we're going to be catering to people in
a for-profit track and a non-profit
track
and i know that mission statements are
the underpinning things
of a non-profit and mission
wanderer mission stray can be a serious
problem so
the importance of testing your idea up
front to make sure that you're staying
faithful to that
you know there's a lot of back end work
that's going to need to happen
i think that non-profits don't have the
same level of agility to be able to
switch necessarily so um i think that's
an important thing for
any of my non-profit people out there to
remember yeah
absolutely thank you for mentioning that
i wasn't aware you would have
non-profits and that's a great point
um let's see i have
you know we work a lot through a very
iterative process
there's a lot of mentoring we do a lot
of pitch workshops so that people
start you know they start writing they
start riffing and then they start
getting more cohesive there are pitch
crits
and the before and afters tend to be
really powerful with the students so i'm
wondering
if you've got an example of a venture
that's sort of like the what not to wear
that ended up turning around and being
successful do you have like a
a good before and after of a team that
might not have had a clear value prop in
the beginning but was able to pivot and
succeed
i i have lots of examples um i was
thinking as you're saying that i was
thinking about the ones that come to
mind for some reason
are mostly mostly medical um
mostly because we just finished up our
i-corps cohort
and this was a particular team um
you know they they went in they had an
adhesive a medical bandage adhesive
that their problem they were trying to
address was
when you have a open wound or a burn
victim
the actual redressing of those wounds
tears
the part of the healed skin
off when there is so it's very painful
and they were trying to address the pain
by
developing an adhesive under this
bandage that would break down
under light a certain type of uv light
and they went to nurses that were
treating
patients on a wound care for us and the
nurses said
we don't care they said don't you aren't
you worried about the pain no
we don't care about the pain this is 35
customer interviews in i said no you
don't care and he said what do you mean
well of course we care generally
but we have to pick one of those two
bandages that are in the cabinet over
there
we don't have any power or influence
ability so they completely
had to pivot out of that segment and
moving from the
wound care nurses they went directly to
the head wound care nurse
and they said well how do we get
different bandages into that cabinet and
she said
i don't care and they're like well what
do you mean you don't care well of
course i care that there's pain and that
there should be alternative solutions
but
we have to go with the ones that are
approved cost-wise that go fit into that
cabinet now there's 65 interviews in
and they've been demoralized one step
along the way
and at the end they eventually said well
who decides which ones go into those
cabinets and it was the the
um reimbursement officer upstairs and
they ended up with the reimbursement
officers good
and he's desperate for anything any
solution that could resolve pain
he's willing to put a more expensive
bandage into that cabinet
if it's going to reduce the pain scores
because he's reimbursed
the hospital system is reimbursed off of
the pain scores see they didn't know
that they didn't understand that
they thought the total solution was just
immediately addressing the pain that the
patient had
but only through up to 80 interviews now
before they realize they have a bigger
solution than they ever could imagine
and they actually had to go back into
the laboratory and readdress the
adhesive because he wanted it to be a
stronger adhesive but break down quicker
and they were already re-engineering so
that team went on to start a
start a company they raised several
million dollars got their new product
issued they're an fda regulatory pathway
now
and they would have never known if
they'd just simply built the product
tried to sell it to
to wound care clinics they would have
never figured that out
i hope that's a little bit of an example
i'm just sort of trying to get over my
personal squeamish factor to see the
heart of the story which was fantastic
sorry about that no not at all yeah
there's several others the one i
mentioned about though there was a heart
trans not a transplant but a heart
pacemaker they had come up with a way of
a
permanent battery met getting power off
the flow of blood through the heart and
transitioning that power back to the
pacemaker
and the problem is that's an interesting
idea because you'd hate to get a
pacemaker and 20 years later have to
open up
do another open-heart surgery to get it
repaired but
or get the battery replaced but they
found out that people don't get
pacemakers until they're late 70s and
they don't live long enough for the
batteries to go down
so there was no need for that however
that is the solution looking for a
problem
the same technology became a turbine to
drive drones
and so you could re-power we repower the
batteries in a drone
they asked themselves well what other
technologies have battery issues and
there were a number of them and that was
the one they focused on so completely
different pivot
wow so just a couple examples
so you spoke a little while ago about
um basically oh you know what
i i know we're running out of time i had
one final question
no i have two questions actually is that
all right with you no it's fine by me
sure sure okay firstly you were talking
about how
um other partners it's not just direct
partners it's just not consumers
um there are a lot of people that are
integrated into the success you were
saying it took 80 interviews to get to
the guy
upstairs who really had the answer so um
do you know as far as as far as those
partnerships are concerned that's really
important
but also when you're creating your own
team partnerships are incredibly
important
um how does one go about identifying the
right team and the right partners
that can contribute to or are aligned
with the value prop
yeah um that's a really good question
um you know there is a bit of a
conundrum because
um a lot of times the value prop is
delivered by the underlying technology
but the underlying technology is
designed developed
maintained and implemented by the team
and so
to a large extent the team is
fundamental to the value proposition
so if if what you have now is an idea
but no solution i mean you have an
idea for how you would solve a
particular problem but you don't have
the solution
you're you're in a pretty good place in
order to
identify through the customer discovery
activity
what is the unique and compelling
problem and how does that manifest in
terms of the pain
what does it limit the customer from
doing and what does if it was resolved
what else could they be doing more
effectively
and and then that speaks very vividly to
the clear
features and attributes and deliverables
that you have to have
in that final product so if you're
one member of what needs to be a
three-member team
and you're doing this assessment and you
come up with that clear articulation
what those compelling attributes are
you can then do a similar type of
activity in in
backward fashion as to identify where
are the key strengths what do i need
with respect to these
you know i mentioned in the business
those key activities and key resources
sometimes
you need a key database in order to
drive a pricing model
you need or you need someone to build
something like that and if you can
articulate that
based on what you heard directly from
the customer in terms of the clear and
compelling features and
attributes they would need in order to
deliver that key value
you can articulate what the skill sets
are that are going to be necessary in
the ultimate team if you're not a team
already going in
or better yet even if you are if you're
open to
part of the learning part of the
discovery being that the team has a
gaping weakness in terms of its ability
to deliver the value
that's just you ought to be honest with
yourself so we've got to we've got to
cap that we've gotta fix it and if again
if you're clear enough in what the
customer needs i think you'll be clear
enough in understanding and isolating
those skill sets
and from there you know uh it just
becomes a networking and marketing
recruiting type of activity that i think
is you know
we're all pretty familiar with
it's not an easy not an easy thing
though that that
i'm usually dealing with teams who are
fixed going in
and when they realize there's a gap they
look for an external partner and they're
never open
as many maybe many of your teams will be
open to
reshaping the team the fundamental team
itself that's that's a great concept
i think that's an important takeaway too
we've got a lot of students who might
have a great idea who don't know who
their teammates need to be
or we might have groups that are looking
for that other person so we're trying to
facilitate the kind of networking
that will enable people to have
awareness of this uh have the
self-awareness to be able to seek the
right teammates and for people in the
community
to have awareness of this opportunity so
that people can find
you know those natural fits and those
critical partners
yeah and sometimes it takes an
intermediary like you to
to facilitate that that's challenging
even if i
am open to hearing that i need help
finding that specific person or persons
that
that can be challenging so yeah we i we
don't have that at ohio state so i may
call
call on you absolutely um we see 100
ideas a year
it's uh it's worth mentioning that you
know
the the competition has primarily been
in person we pivoted sort of
uh as gracefully as we could in the
spring for obvious reasons
we're doing the entire program virtually
this year
um most of the mit students are off
campus it's a year-ish long program so
we want to make it fair and equitable
for everybody so
to that end um students anywhere can be
part of teams
um teams just have to have one mit
student so
if you have any students who might be
interested in this we certainly can try
to broker something to get
you know get this on the map because at
least where zoom is concerned
there's like the sky's the limit on
these teams and partnerships
so what's the what's the deadline for
when the team has to be finalized
that's a great question the applications
are due the first week of february but i
think that as
the projects and programs sort of go
through various iterations
um you know i think we should have a
great idea of what teams are
roughly by the first week of february
but there could still be a little bit
you know through one-on-one mentorship
students might figure out that
oh we really need another person here so
in order to
maximize success we are probably open to
the idea of
you know adding people as needed
okay great no i definitely would have
people interested so
perfect stay connected let me know let's
do that
um theo did you have one final question
before we wrap up
yeah absolutely so dr camp i think he
tried to reference this in your uh
your spoilers but i think if you have
any uh if you
could share one kind of pearl of wisdom
or one
key takeaway for teams competition i
think that would be really helpful
for the teams here and those watching
asynchronously
yeah no thanks that's a great way to
wrap up
you know i in thinking about that
there's um
there's so many pieces that go together
and i don't know if you you guys put
more weight
on the final presentation in terms of
determining winners
uh or not or if it's just kind of a
cumulative effect as
as teams move through the program but
um the ability to tell an effective
story and when i
again heard that it's about a
five-minute presentation with the five
minutes of q
a i wanted to emphasize that if the
team's not able to tell the story uh in
a compelling convincing fashion
in the five minutes they'd better be
able to answer the questions
in a compelling convincing way because
they're going to get the key questions
that the reviewers judges whatever
they're called are going to be listening
for
however my advice would be to
by getting familiar and testing very
clearly and honestly
openly questioning and challenging your
own understanding and underlying
assumptions
you're going to have a much more
compelling way to tell the key
considerations
you know whatever that whether it be
market that differentiates your
opportunity or it's the compelling
solution
or whether it be just what kind of
economic or social
or human impact you're able to have
you you need to isolate not be able to
articulate what that
really moving moment that moving element
is um it's not enough to just cr you
know dotting eyes and crossing t's
there's probably so many good ideas in
this competition
the team that can get that idea across
in a believable
realistic way and the best believability
is that you've if you've either done it
or if you haven't done it you have
have connected directly with those end
users and partners so that they'll tell
you those who have done it
can tell you that this is doable this is
believable
in other words it's it's making it real
as
real as possible and the moment you have
to say i think i believe
you know you realize that's a that's a
compelling gap that's an area of
challenge that you're going to have
making it real making it concise
hitting the critical elements that make
your opportunity differentiated from the
others and
uh having and because now you've done
that you'll have
so much more confidence and in terms of
how you tell that story
it doesn't sound like one thing that was
the best
possible answer now anybody who is here
for our kickoff conference and keynote
and anybody who's watching who
you know will watch this who saw that
first event it all comes down to
storytelling there are so many
entrepreneurship innovation initiatives
at the institute and everybody has their
own sort of value added and
apart from being arts driven the thing
that people come here and the big
takeaway
is storytelling um it's it's
sort of the underpinning of the entire
operation so
uh i promise we didn't feed dr camp that
answer it just
fits so perfectly within the theme of
being successful with helping to launch
your venture so
that couldn't have been better
cathedral background i gotta say amen
exactly um hey if i can be at the final
event
i'd love to see some of those great
stories absolutely
we will definitely be in touch that
would be fantastic um
so if any of the three of you stalwart
soldiers here have any questions let me
know um
we can also forward things on to dr camp
so you know if that is it for everybody
then um i'm just gonna
thank dr camp for his time it was
fantastic having you here we really
appreciate this
and it was so engaging especially even
for zoom
you know it was it was wonderful we
can't thank you enough
well glad to be with you thanks again
perfect thank you so much